Performers:
When I say "Body," you say "Hype!"
Body. Hype. Body. Hype.
Performers:
When I say "Body," you say "Hype!"
Body. Hype. Body. Hype. Body. Body. Hype. Hype. Body. Body. Hype. Hype.
(music)
Amy Achenbaum:
BodyHype Dance Company is a student-run co-ed dance group on campus.
We put on two shows a year with tons of different pieces choreographed
Amy Achenbaum:
by the students with all different kinds of dancing ranging from hip hop,
lyrical, jazz, contemporary, sometimes we'll throw in something new....
(music)
Sar Medoff:
It's all these beautiful, beautiful people sitting around having a good time.
Occasionally we dance.
Brittany Kelleher:
People should come to our spring show because we have one of the most fun shows on campus.
We have crazy audiences with everyone cheering and screaming and jumping up and down
Brittany Kelleher:
and we live for that, and we encourage it.
And there's always a huge chance to see one of your good friends or someone on campus you didnt know even
Brittany Kelleher:
dances. We have great talent, really cute girls, you know, really hot guys too, so it's
a great show to see, and it's a ton of fun!
(music)
Brian Boone:
What does BodyHype mean to you?
Chris Greco:
Family, definitely family.
TJ Ramirez:
I don't like you....
(music)